happy may the fourth and we do think
this is a national holiday for us the
may the fourth events for us have
traditionally become a customer
appreciation day we'll want to celebrate
may the 4th with our fans
so we have the voice of princess leia
from rebels julie dolan
will be signing with us today in store
remember that
experience going to the movie theater
coming out of the theater
being taken to the toy store i remember
buying a vintage snow trooper was my
first
figure that i opened when it comes to
star wars star wars has just been an
unstoppable
force it is constant branding a lot of
times that because there's been a few
new products that have come out like the
mandalorian like it's
unearthed new collectors but they've
been so relevant for so long they've
just strengthened
the collectors they had already built
when it comes to star wars stuff you can
never have enough
vader boba fett or luke now what you're
looking at is our vintage star wars and
i wish we had more in stock than we do
it's a very popular portion of the store
these are vintage original star wars
figures that you're seeing here
77 to 1983 and this this is the stuff
my childhood grew up on we try to keep
them restocked as much as possible so
always buying so you've got a collection
you like to sell come see us